you know I was 23 and my brother would
have been 19 and yet you know we felt
like we already spent years thinking
about these things
reading young studying Tibetan yoga
going to India taking psychedelics and
I'm not a true believer or some kind of
soft-headed busiest for Atlantis or
something like that
my approaches to reality is always that
what can you show me you say you've got
them why I mean what is it and then if
they say well you have to sweep up
around the ashram where you have to kiss
my ring very simple thing no no thank
you
so it was as though that method actually
finally paid off and that out there in
the center of the jungle days and days
walking in with no way out and taking
the mushrooms which we weren't really
familiar with this was like our
discovery encounter with
it seemed like reality just sort of
opened itself and my brother thought he
saw a way not only to you know fulfill
the hippie dream of the high that lasts
forever but also to sort of
somehow wrap it around itself and turn
it into a kind of object in
three-dimensional space which then and
now is a concept very hard to wrap your
mind around and it would have just been
some freaky
idea you know if it weren't for the fact
that he seemed then to be able to
deliver her on it to a certain degree
and I felt ever since that we're locked
inside some kind of like a work of art
like a novel or a play because the
mushrooms in a way lifted the veil on
the future they
but many times people on drugs get
grandiose ideas so you couldn't tell now
is this grandiosity or is this real
prophecy but it was all about how there
would be a technique revealed that would
be bought one level completely trivial
on another level completely
transcendental and I had no idea what
this technique would be well then over
the next five or six years it became
clear to me that what it was was it was
the growing of the mushroom that you
know you can take three dozen mason jars
and drive that you buy at the health
food store and six weeks later you and
your entire flat full of friends and
acquaintances can walk into a symbiotic
relationship with an alien being who's
well familiar with the history of the
galaxy and so far in the Sun was like
craziness is unleashed I mean I don't
think
realize it's this that psilocybin is not
exactly a drug I mean it is if you only
take it a few times in your life and at
low doses at loud parties but never get
but that take large doses of love and
darkness and it will appalled the most
radical people around because it
presents itself as an mind with an
agenda
you